day seven  of the general election campaign i'm  here  in the southwest of england in devon a  key battleground  that may determine the election uh today  george osborne has been anticipating  tomorrow's uh coming into the law of new  pensions freedoms  which is a policy laser guided by the  conservatives  trying to shore up their support amongst  certain mid 50s jeremy clarkson fans he  might argue  people who've been tempted over to uk  but have large pension pots  um this is a key battleground why  because if the conservatives keep all  their seats  they feel the majority is here to be won  or who  the liberal democrats coalition fracture  size  one fly in the ointment in that strategy  though  things like this signs on the side of  the road just outside a shopping center  anti-eu ukip rising force here  in the south west but if they do well  that is the lib dems one of their best  hopes of keeping some of the seats here  odd bed fellows this extraordinary  election  is created